hey guys to celebrate hitting 80,000
subscribers I'm gonna explain what you
need to make youtube videos in the same
way that I do a few of you might
remember that I promised to do this
video a couple of months ago and while
it took me longer than expected to get
round to it we are finally here people
and I'm gonna explain everything there
is to know before we begin I feel like
there's two important disclaimers that I
should mention the first thing is that
everything I show you in this video is
what I use to make content right now but
this was definitely not always the case
for many of my early videos if you go
and take a look back at them the audio
quality especially is just terrible and
that is because I didn't have like a
legit external microphone everything
about it was just low quality but over
time I've made different improvements in
certain areas and as the channel began
to grow you know I improved on those
improvements which is all built up to
what I use to make videos today and for
the purposes of this video you know to
not waste anyone's time I won't be
covering anything that I've used along
the way I'm specifically talking about
the stuff that I used right now secondly
the other important thing is this is not
a tutorial on how to edit videos
I'm sure if you type it in on YouTube
there will be a ton of teachers who can
show you how to edit videos and not only
am I not one of them but I've also never
watched them myself the way I edit right
now is just the result of trial and
error over a period of time for those
who are new to my channel I've uploaded
at least one video every single week for
the last forty three consecutive weeks
and so for that reason that's why I've
been able to get a little bit better at
editing when I started this crazy
journey in terms of making all this
content I did and still do have a
full-time job so what that means is that
YouTube takes up most of my free time
which is fine because I love to do it I
love to talk about anime specifically
but anyway my advice is just that if you
don't want to watch tutorials like you
know the same way that I don't then just
experiment around don't be afraid to try
new things from week to week and you
will definitely see progress I can
guarantee it starting with the audio
side of things
I currently record each video with a
pseudo track microphone which I managed
to get for 51 pounds which roughly
translates to 62 dollars for my American
viewers I was checking earlier this week
and the price has now risen slightly but
it's still around that $60 to $70 range
but in my opinion you know it's a really
good microphone for the price and I've
never really considered replacing it as
I feel it does the job well I record my
videos on Final Cut Pro using this
microphone and sometimes in the past you
guys have said that my audio isn't loud
enough which is probably the only
complaint that I've ever had about it
and most of the time what I do now is
I'll just record the video like I'm
doing right now and then after it's done
I'll crank up the audio and since I've
started doing that no one's really
complained about the volume so I'm
assuming it's okay but if it's not then
please do let me know in the comments
below also any music you've heard in my
videos is directly from the free YouTube
music library they have a ton of
different songs and sound effects for
virtually anything you can think of and
everything there is completely
royalty-free so you literally can use it
in whatever video or content you make
and no one's gonna you know strike you
down or send you a email like it's all
completely free so if you want to be on
the safe side then that's definitely
what you should use and in terms of
audio that is actually pretty much it I
mean this is the microphone that I use
and this is the music that I use I think
that there's not really much more to it
than that but moving on in terms of
basic visuals like I said Final Cut Pro
is what I use to edit and due to the
sheer amount of just content you know
pitches videos all this stuff that I use
in a typical video most of my projects
end up looking like what you currently
see on screen throughout the video I'll
use a lot of effects which can be found
over here in Final Cut Pro and in
between clips I'll typically use
transitions which can be found over here
again if you want to learn about how to
use this stuff in action then there are
many tutorials out there but for the
most part I think you'll find it quite
straightforward once you get started
Final Cut Pro comes with a ton of
effects so if you're not picky then I'm
sure there'll be something for whatever
you're thinking of but in my case you
know I was using them for a while and I
got a bit bored so I bought two
additional plugins that I've purchased
for Final Cut and these were made by a
company called pixel film studios the
main thing that I bought from them that
I use the most often is the cartoon mega
pack and this allows me to do epic
hand-drawn transitions like this one and
this one and that one but not to mention
you get random effects that aren't
really transitions they're just things
you can throw in the video anywhere and
I've done this for about two more
now I reckon two or three months and I
gotta say it was definitely worth the
cost for me as I basically use it in
every video that I've made since then
however I'm not saying that this is
something you need to get because
honestly most of my videos on YouTube do
not have any effects like this my
channel was still able to grow so I
would say it's not necessary but if you
think it will add value then yeah
definitely try it out
the other thing that I got from pixel
Studios was an audio visualizer package
what this allows me to do is that in
certain videos like the one you're
currently watching
whenever I'm speaking the the audio that
I'm saying is then visually represented
on the screen and I've got to be honest
I do not use this often the only time I
really use it is what I'm doing
collaborations with other youtubers so
it kind of like shows you who's talking
but on screen I think this video right
here is the only time that I've used it
when it's just me in the video so it's
not something again none of this stuff
is necessary what I thought I'd let you
guys know in case you were interested in
using it yourself a funny story about
this package was that after I bought it
I realized that there was an audio
visualizer too on their website so like
I bought the old defunct version when
they already had a brand new part 2
version I didn't even see an [ __ ]
which was really annoying when I when I
first bought this but on this website
right now at least when I recorded this
video the audio visualizer pack 1 and
pack 2 they were the same price so if I
was you I'd probably get the second pack
which seems to be more updated and have
cooler things to it I don't know if I
will personally be buying a second pack
because I don't really use this too
often like I said but yeah I would just
say if you're gonna buy it do not make
my mistake as far as equipment goes
that's basically everything there is to
know with the exception of one important
thing and that is of course the hub that
brings everything together which is my
2015 MacBook Pro which is now probably
on its last legs because it just runs
out of battery way too fast
but I still you know I quite like it
it's very sturdy it does the job and
crucially Final Cut Pro only works on
Apple devices as far as I know because
Apple are the ones who make it one thing
I would like in the comments if you have
a PC I would like someone to just let me
know what is the best alternative to
Final Cut Pro for PC users because I
honestly can't tell you but I'm sure
someone in the comments will know I've
been using Final Cut
proce since about November and it was
actually a really interesting case study
right because when I use Final Cut Pro
for the first time that video which I
made was my first ever video to get six
figures before then I think my highest
video was 10,000 views and once I made a
video on Final Cut Pro it got six
figures like pretty much within a week
and then the video after that got six
figures and then I think this happened
like three or four times in a row like I
just got four or five six figure videos
I'm not saying this was entirely down to
Final Cut Pro of course but I mean you
got to admit that correlation is pretty
crazy
maybe I just say invest in the best
software that you can for editing
because I think people respond really
well to good visual I don't wanna say
effects but good visual editing because
I was able to do a lot more on Final Cut
Pro than I was on my previous software
which which we don't speak about anymore
but it wasn't very good the final thing
that I'm gonna mention is the process
that I use to make videos so firstly
I'll record the audio on Final Cut Pro
using my studio track microphone and
then after that Stan I'll cut it up to
remove anything that I don't want which
includes bloopers or just you know blank
space where I'm thinking about stuff so
it forms a pretty coherent audio track
but it's not the complete video just yet
because once that's done I'll add the
different visuals like the pictures and
the videos and the transitions and all
the effects and everything and usually
whilst I'm doing that or realize that
there are certain parts of the audio
that I should cut which I didn't realize
the first time around so that's always a
good you know this is kind of like the
refining part of the process and once
for that Stan you got all the visuals
all the audio that's when I basically
have my completed video usually I'll add
the music after all this is done and I
turn it down to minus 40 decibels and
then I check over my audio once again
just to make sure everything's good oh
yeah and I crank up the sound on my on
the audio that I recorded with just a
little bit just to you know make it a
bit louder once that file is ready I
just do what you see on screen I just
export it and once that's exported and
then always I send it to my phone
actually because one thing that I do
typically is I upload videos from my
phone for some reason it's just always
way faster than doing it on the computer
and I have no idea why but it just
always seems to work so that's just
that's my ritual this point I'm sure
there's no science to it but yeah that's
just what works for me if this video has
been helpful to you in any way then do
be sure to give it a like and the links
to everything that I've mentioned today
are in the description so you can buy
the mic you can buy Final Cut Pro you
can i'm not going to link to the macbook
because I don't even think they sell
anymore
and if you want to get the one that I
have which I don't know why you would
but um you can check on eBay or
something like that I'm sure there's
many people trying to sell it thank you
guys for watching and make sure to sub
to the channel as well because we are
still on that road to 100k pizza